have you read his autobiography it's
fantastic is amazing I couldn't look at
him look look at him no it's all do it
together come on get up bigger bigger
hello my bell everything is just
stunning just stunning it's a great
movie I mean and be really happy with
the film made about you
I wouldn't change a thing so there you
go
and of course this woman is amazing I'm
going go to heaven I'm a Brit too
so okay let's hope so I hope that Kat
Singh doesn't win because it's crap but
anyway what cats
[Music]
[Music]
the way we were I'm going back I leave
tonight straight after the awards I get
on a plane and I arrive on Tuesday
morning I play on Tuesday night come in
for this because he produced it song and
town put his heart and soul into it so
we will here celebrate it doesn't matter
if you win or you don't win because you
honestly it really doesn't we're proud
of what we did and we're just
celebrating that's it it's hold on
before everybody moves out and before
you before you move Henry wanted to come
down and take a picture with you Henry
Winkler wanted to come over and take a
picture with you guys and say hello yeah
yeah here you guys get in there I'll
take it you guys get in there oh you got
you got it okay I'll take okay right
here we go out and here we go all right
here we go here we go here we go here we
go
[Music]